Hey everyone, hope you're all doing well.
Just jumping on for the fourth module,
which is Session Liquidity. Okay,
again, super simple. It's gonna be a real fast,
uh, module. Session Liquidity is drawn out for you,
right? Essentially we have three modules. Three different areas that we're focused on.
We have Asia, we have London,
and we have New York. Okay? These are just killzone times.
It's a period throughout Asia,
London, and New York where most of the institutions and banks are trading.
That's where most of the liquidity is. Okay? It's pretty simple.
Like, it's already marked up for you.
You don't really need to know anything about the liquidity, right?
I suppose, really, we'll just explain which ones are which.
Now, I have mine as,
If you look, UTC minus 4,
Asia started at 8pm and ends at 12am,
okay? And it's in blue. London starts at 2am
and ends at 5,
and it's in green. New Zealand. New York starts at 7am and ends at
10am, and it's in orange, okay?
There are session liquidity zones. Now how can you use this to your favor,
okay? Now, go test this.
Go look for it, right? We have, so,
and setups, and, you know,
we have a strategy called session liquidity that we use,
right, to, to use these kill zones,
which is why we have them on the indicator, you know, you've probably seen
on Lewis' YouTube channel and things many times, like, Lewis has these session, uh,
areas marked up, everyone's on those,
ask him how we got them. This is how they're here.
Okay. You don't need to do anything that already turned on. Settings should already
be correct. If not, just check. Just turn your time to UTC minus four
and make sure that you have the same times as me. The one times
that I just took you over. How can you use this to your advantage?
Well, I'll just give you a little clue,
right? Which you can go test. We don't trade Asia.
We trade in London and New York, right?
For London. Let's just see how this looks,
right? How can you use these? Well,
we use the highs and the lows as little liquidity as an area to
target. So I know that when London opens,
right, the Asia's low and high are areas to target.
They're areas with liquidity. Now,
if we take the low first, For the rest of the session,
from London going into New York. Because we've already took Asia's low,
that liquidity is gone. The only liquidity that is left is the
high. So we could look to target that high.
Okay. What happened the day before?
Asia's high was taken first. Liquidity of the high was gone.
Now the liquidity of the low is what's left. So we look to target
that. Asia's low was taken first.
Only the high is left. So we look to target that.
Okay. We're trying to get in positions in here on a lower time frame.
Okay. Around these points, we're looking for positions.
You can do the same one. Also with New York. If New York then
trades at London's high, you can look to short.
Okay. What happened on the day before here?
We took Asia's low first. Only the high is left.
So we're looking to get in, longs to the upside.
Now it doesn't always work like this. You know, you can't always get in.
You can't everything right. You can't be a hundred percent perfect.
So you can see here we had the low taken, price mounted.
We just continue, continue from London. Here you can see it didn't even
happen in London, right? In Frank, before London opened,
we actually swept the low. Then we went and targeted the highs.
We took the highs, then we targeted the lows. Okay?
We took the low in Frank, we targeted the high.
You can see it plays out all the time.
We take the low first, in Frank. We then take the high.
We take the high, we take the low. We take the low,
we take the high. So that's how you use session liquidity.
We know that there's always going to be liquidity in these highs and lows
to target. So if the low's gone first,
the high's left. That's how we're going to use session liquidity.
Now there's more about that in the master key.
You've probably seen it. We give you one of our strategies and our set
ups, which teaches you how to actually get involved in these,
in these areas. But that's a little walkthrough.
There's not much to go over. You know, there's not much information there.
It's just that simple, right? It's just a killzone. You know,
you have your killzone in Asia, you have your killzone in London,
you have your killzone in New York. The times are,
as I said, UTC minus 4,
8pm till 12am,
2am till 5pm. And then 7am till 10am.
It's pretty simple. That's it.
And we want to use the highs and lows. You can go test something
around that, I just gave you some good clues. Any questions?
Let me know.